[Musique]
est-ce qu'on se connaît je suis le
nouveau prof de littérature
vous vivez dans le quartier
l'ancienne maison des Beatles
et vous avez emménagé quand
j'ai entendu parler de l'horrible
histoire qui est arrivé à ce garçon il
paraît qu'elle est hantée
est-ce que vous avez remarqué des
événements inhabituels
[Musique]
il se passe des trucs vraiment chelous
c'est notre chance de connaître enfin
toute la vérité
pourquoi tu as fait ça un mec c'est pas
cool du tout ce qu'un démon qui prend
possession d'un appareil photo ça existe
pas
[Musique]
ça va
infirmière
tout est lié il cherche à se venger
c'est à cause de ce que nos parents lui
ont fait
oh mon Dieu on est des enfants de
meurtriers
[Musique]
c'est justement pour cette raison qui
nous arrive tout ça
c'est trop dangereux tout ça va très mal
finir
il serait peut-être temps que tu la
racontes tout
viens avec moi
oh
mon dieu il faut qu'on parle et pourquoi
James sans les bonbons à la pastèque que
j'allais dire
[Musique]